Denmark is going to outlaw bestiality
yeah that's right animal sex has been
legal in Denmark and people were taking
advantage of it to the point that there
was actually like a tourism based on
animal sex believe it or not 76% of the
Danish population now believe that
banning sex with animals is the right
thing to do so they're gonna go ahead
and do it that means twenty four percent
is still down with animal sex all right
you know five one in one one in five or
four or okay I'm not I'm not am a
surgeon you're not a mathematician it's
actually worse than you thought Jamie
it's it's one in four it really is
we've got a quote from Denmark's Food
and Agriculture Minister I've decided
that we should ban sex with animals that
is happening for numerous reasons the
most important is that in the vast
majority of cases it is an attack
against the animal that's a great line
and under all circumstances any doubts
about it should go to the animals
benefit they naturally cannot say no to
go along with it therefore it should be
banned I like the part in the vast
majority of cases it's an attack on the
animal as opposed to the lamb that's
been giving you the eye all week the
fact that he felt like that was almost
political statement wasn't that that was
like the type of stuff that we make fun
of in America where they can't really
like say anything so they end up saying
saying that sounds that much worse well
let's just just oppose that it was it
was the other way around because I don't
think animals are thinking God you noted
Dave looks pretty good but that's
against the rules
if an animal attacked a human in a
sexual manner we'd shoot the animal yeah
so just food for thought my dog has hump
my leg plenty of times and he's a good
boy you keep dog treats up your right
leg which is a little weird Jimmy yeah
it is a little weird it's funny that
they had to that was just funny that he
had to release a statement saying why
we're gonna do one of the reasons are
numerous numerous I could think of a
million reasons but I guess the big one
is because you're
again and that's the main one that would
be the big one that would be the big one
don't [ __ ] a fight over yeah doesn't
surprise you that it's Denmark like is
the first world country
I guess there might be some third world
countries where there wouldn't have laws
in place because there's a lot of places
on earth where there aren't we don't
know the system that we have like where
you maybe would go out there over the
law and it's so I guess a fairly
good-looking people so I don't know why
they can't just have sex with each other
makes you wonder well this is a well the
Denmark NAMBLA Association the National
Organization of man-beast and they're
pushing back against this they're
pushing back muscles with their hips but
what is the what is there a group
pushing back against this as any that
there's anyone actually well someone's
got to be upset it's pushing back and
four people are we being too dismissive
of the people that want to have sex with
animals I mean there's a fetish for
everything right there is a fetish for
you name something someone wants to have
this desk yes somewhat I mean somebody
that's room so it's I don't want to tell
you but no but really there's a fetish
for everything so are we being too
dismissive but now people that probably
are treating the animal
you may take em out for dinner yeah
sorry after the old feedbag no because I
mean in general if you're with your
fetish if your cork whatever doesn't
hurt anyone doesn't it you know encroach
on anybody else's liberties then have a
good time with the sheet that's what I'm
saying yeah I mean it's going bad they
can't say no so therefore you can't do
it and that's the segment okay
[Music]